tommy dorfman wants to make things clear
she's reintroduced herself to the world
as a woman
dorfman who played ryan shaver on 13
reasons why
publicly discussed her transition in an
interview with tory peters
published in time on thursday revealing
for a year now i have been privately
identifying and
living as a woman a trans woman
continuing she says
i view today as a reintroduction to me
as a woman
having made a transition medically
coming out
is always viewed as this grand reveal
but i was never not out
today is about clarity i am a trans
woman
my pronouns are she and her my name is
tommy
if you follow tommy on instagram you may
have noticed that she has been
documenting the changes in her
appearance and style slowly over the
last several months
something tommy says made her feel less
in control
i recognize that transitioning is
beautiful why not let the world see
what that looks like so i kept on
instagram
a diaristic time capsule instead one
that shows a body living in a more fluid
space
however i've learned as a public facing
person that my refusal to clarify
can strip me of the freedom to control
my own narrative
with this medical transition there has
been discourse about my body and it
began to feel
overwhelming the 29 year old also says
that she will not be changing her name a
name that was given to her
after her mother's brother passed away
shortly after she was born
but she does say that she is no longer
interested in playing
male characters and recognizes this
could change
the course of her career i am most
recognized for playing a [ __ ] gay poet
on a soap opera
and i feared that by actively
transitioning in my personal life i
would lose
whatever career i've been told i'm
supposed to have
however that does not seem to be the
case she just landed
a lead role in lena dunham's sharps deck
we'll be starring in a limited series
titled fracture and is gearing up
to direct an adaptation of mace
endeavours i wish you all the best
summing up her journey so far dorfman
says
transitioning has been liberating and
clarifying
and we can't wait to see more from tommy
if you like
lgbtq news make sure you like and
subscribe to this channel
oh hey there if you want more lgbtq news
and exclusive interviews
click subscribe or watch these videos